it's a Monday edition of PFT ot I say
this every time we have this extra show
set aside for topics we either didn't
get to during PFT live or that we would
like to talk about some more but in some
cases there are developments as the
stories we talked about that actually
constitute things we haven't discussed
at all even though we've been all over
the topic the Antonio Brown helmets saga
Chris during the show in rapport of the
NFL tweeted this Raiders receiver
Antonio Brown may not be yet out of
options
my understanding is two more helmets
same shut air advantage that he prefers
are being tested for possible use they
were made in different years than his
original one tested at 2014 and it's one
T 10 my reaction to that it doesn't
matter in testing the air advantage last
week they came to the conclusion that
that helmet is not permitted you can go
out and try to find other shut air
advantages it doesn't matter that
helmets off the list here's what I think
is happening and this is the benefit of
having reporters who are on your payroll
you can push stuff like this out there
because it makes you look like you're
being fair you're being reasonable
hey we're tests will gladly fail as many
shut air advantage he can show up with
yeah it's so obvious that's what they're
doing here
they're not gonna pass one of these
helmets this isn't gonna be the way out
of the box this is about the NFL setting
itself up in the court of public opinion
and also if there's another grievance
they don't want to get any tough
questions about whether or not they
tested his specific preferred models
that he found no no they they tested
them all and we gave everything a fair
shake and they all failed sorry don't
blame us yeah no it certainly seems that
way definitely seems propaganda ish as
far as that's concerned and again listen
I understand the NFL messed up I they're
they obviously have realized that that's
why they closed this loophole is it fair
to Antonio Brown no not completely but
we have to look at it from this
standpoint too for the NFL I mean oh
okay you know how's it going
look if they look like they kind of bent
the rules or didn't close some loophole
that they should have have closed right
and Antonio Brown gets to wear his shut
air advantage helmet from 2011 or
whatever your with one that would have
been legal and then he goes over the
middle and gets a bad concussion during
the year what does the NFL gonna say
then it is Antonio Brown I'm gonna hold
the NFL liable now that he's they let me
wear this helmet that's not actually
didn't pass the test why did they let me
do that you know so that we also have to
take that into account that the NFL's in
a tough spot here especially with the
magnitude and just the attention around
this to where they have to protect
themselves legally as well hey Chris
okay that's fine
yeah but I'm gonna turn it back around
though okay what had happened what would
what would have happened last year if
Tom Brady had suffered a serious
concussion wearing a helmet model that
had been banned by the league but he got
a one-year grace period just like Aaron
Rodgers and others the same argument
that's unsafe helmet yeah that you've
determined should not be worn but we're
gonna let you wear it for one more year
so you can get used to you know whatever
your new reality is gonna be after you
can no longer wear the helmet model you
want to wear so that's good for every
that this is a great example of what
happens in these settings where for
everything the NFL says there's a
response yeah everything Antonio Brown
says there's a response and I think he
just needs to follow another grievance
and hope that the arbitrator who is
neutral and independent supposedly will
say you know what you guys kind of
screwed him here yeah there was a
loophole and then you clumsily tried to
close it and you're not giving him the
one-year grace period to get accustomed
to some other helmet like you did with
others let him wear the helmet for one
more year and that could be the biggest
victory he can hope just argue that we
think he might have had a one-year grace
period though cuz he knew how he didn't
well he so you say you didn't have a
grace period okay no last year was the
tenth year of the helmet that he wore
that's where that's where these issues
get confused he had a helmet that was
more than ten years old that cannot be
recertified by noxee noxee is willing to
recertify the shut air advantage helmets
he found that less than ten years old
this isn't about yeah he said new the as
of last week he still thought he was on
so I'm doing
new helmet so like didn't he have right
right I'm a new shutted air advantage
it's less than ten years old that's the
point
well you can't afford that though Mike
before all of that he still knew that he
that's why he missed OTAs and walked out
of the locker room seven different times
because they were telling him you have
to wear a new helmet until they found
this loophole so they can argue that
they kind of gave him a grace period
year either way but he found a loophole
to them ding gimmick they didn't he's
never gotten a no because his helmet
model wasn't banned and took a rush to
ban it last week my point is this yeah
and and we didn't have this as one of
the benefits of doing this because we
don't have people telling us to go to
break alright um if he had when he was
drafted by the Steelers 2010 on his way
in equipment manager hey I like to shut
our advantage
get me a brand-new shut air advantage
they get him one that was made in 2010
we wouldn't know about any of this right
now right because the shut our advantage
that he's wearing would be less than 10
years old not Siri certifies it it's not
prohibited the guy was on the frickin
cover of Madden last year this shut air
advantage is still being used in plain
sight nobody bothered to notice it's
only because it became an issue that the
NFL is like well no we have to test the
shut air advantage and sorry Antonio it
fails that's that like it at a basic
level of fairness that's what bothers me
about this people ask me why do you care
about it because I feel like the guys
getting screwed here
I think it's ludicrous to consider not
playing football in any helmet that is
acceptable for thirty million dollars
over the next two years and I'd like to
think he's smart enough to realize that
and I do think there's a certain element
of hey this is the first time he's ever
been told no in his life and that's why
he's so pissed off but I still think at
a level of basic fundamental fairness
they need to give him one year in a
helmet model that was not banned until
they rushed last week to ban it Chris
I know but ok but he was still being
told before all this that you have to
get a new helmet it doesn't matter okay
a new ID bit but he could get a shot any
damage all that stuff
Mike she had five months for this to get
his head wrapped around that I need a
new helmet he just found out but but
there's there's a difference between
getting your head wrapped around needing
a new helmet when it's not football
season and actually going into football
season with that new helmet he had hope
and you know what shame on his
representatives in shame on the Raiders
for not recognizing you know what here's
easy way to solve the problem let's go
find a shut our advantage less than 10
years old people I don't know why it had
to take one of our readers to figure it
out when there are people who are
getting paid to give this guy advice
yeah I mean it's it's an Oprah
I mean how think about this how
dysfunctional are the Raiders that no
one there was able to realize wait a
minute
this helmet hasn't been banned this
model hasn't been banned
we just can't recertify it through noxee
because it's more than ten years old so
let's go find one that's less than 10
years old I mean it we're talking about
a minimal level of functioning brain
here to realize this loophole and of
course I I didn't reach that that level
either but it wasn't my job it was the
job of the Raiders Drew Rosenhaus the
the legal team that was assisting and
aiding Antonio Brown and they all
screwed up yeah they all missed it yes
it is yeah yeah now the NFL is now the
NFL's blown it by rushing to ban the
helmet and not giving him one year grace
period I'd file the grievance yeah I got
you I totally get you alright so a
bigger picture to the extent that the
Raiders are now exasperated with Antonio
Brown to the point where mike Mayock
issues a lengthy statement where it's
clear that they want him to I guess for
lack of a better term shut or get off
the pot the who's to who's to blame in
Oakland for the fact that they should
have known they knew or should have
known what they were getting into with
Antonio Brown they rushed into it
they gave him 30 million guaranteed what
did they think was going to be different
Chris day and surely if Jon Gruden calls
Mike Tomlin you think Mike Tom is gonna
lie to him about what a pain in the ass
Antonio Brown has been I don't think so
who's who's to blame for welcoming this
guy with opening arms and and
you know acting surprised that he's
behaving this way yeah I mean ultimately
I think this is one that got to go back
to Jon Gruden that's what his butts on
the line that's why you know it's why I
think we're seeing him not make the
comments of yesterday that mike Mayock
made as far as drawing that line in the
sand because he knows he's the reason
Antonio Brown is there he wants Antonio
Brown to be his new toy and he's trying
to play as you said during the show
today he's good cop so he can continue
to continue to be good cop and keep
Antonio Brown in good spirits and hey
the offense is around you and I'm
designing all these plays for you and
mike Mayock can be bad cop and and
certainly say no this nonsense has to
stop even though that's what Jon Gruden
saying as well but he's gonna let mike
Mayock say it and be the bad guy and you
know at the very least I just hope this
gives all everybody a little sympathy to
Mike Tomlin in Pittsburgh that would be
my big point here I mean everybody
talked about lack of institutional
control when it came to you Antonio
Brown and Mike Talman and we're seeing
right now that man there's not many
institutions that can control this guy
it's just not that easy
he and he isn't a phenomenal football
player but I will defend Mike Talman in
this aspect he's not the GM he didn't
have final say on the roster there was a
true GM in Pittsburgh there you know
here with Oakland Jon Gruden we know has
complete and total powers so I think
that's where it has to start as far as
you know at least we're gonna hold
somebody responsible it's him one of the
things I poked around a little bit last
week but it was difficult because the
Steelers organization was dealing with
the untimely passing and unexpected
passing of receivers coach Darrell Drake
I'm trying to figure out and I was at
the time and it kind of faded off the
radar screen as the story shifted and
changed but I'm gonna double back on
this I'm curious did the Steelers know
what was coming with this helmet issue
and did they realize based upon their 10
years with Antonio Brown this isn't
gonna end well and we better just you
know to the extent that there's a stew
of factors that go into a decision like
this I can't help but wonder whether at
some level they knew they're avoiding
this potential maybe shut our advantage
shut storm that
we got it we got we got a thousand of
these punch but you know did they did
they know it and did they did they
deliberately say we want to avoid this
and now they're sitting back saying hey
the Raiders are dealing with what we
were gonna have to deal with if we
hadn't traded that's a great question I
mean it is I would like to know the
answer to that too I will say this just
from people I've talked to around the
league I got a good feeling though that
the Steelers knew before Antonio Brown
had his meltdown late in the season and
the rift between him and Ben
Roethlisberger not showing up I think
they had a good inkling that Antonio
Brown was about to stir the pot and that
he was afraid that he might not see any
more money in Pittsburgh and he was
gonna force himself out of town I think
they had at least a few warning signs
and I don't know if they were totally
shocked by some of the antics Antonio
Brown pulled at the end of the season
and into the offseason to make sure that
he got out of their aisle I have
certainly been led to believe that well
he got what he wanted by way of a
contract that carried 30 million fully
guaranteed but he isn't gonna get any of
it he's gonna have to pay back the
million that he already got in the form
of a signing bonus if he doesn't just
grab a different helmet and show up for
work unless he's got something else up
his sleeve that can work and that only
thing that I can envision is a grievance
attacking the NFL's abrupt decision to
test the shut our advantage to eliminate
that as a an acceptable model that a
player can use and not give him a
one-year grace period to move forward in
that helmet all right let's move on to
Tennessee there's been a lot of chatter
about Ryan Tannehill possibly
supplanting Marcus Mariota at some point
as the starting quarterback Ryan
Tannehill recently said essentially
that's news to me
he sees his role as the number two and
he's not aware of any competition and
maybe he's just not paying attention
Chris because there's definitely a
palpable feeling out there that
Tannehill could put Marcus Mariota on a
short leash going into the 2019 season I
it seems that way you're right and just
reading between the lines the way Ryan
Tannehill has played the first two weeks
of the preseason
I mean hey there's a lot of questions
surrounding Marcus Mariota I do expect
Marcus Mariota unless he just went out
there and threw like three interceptions
this week in the preseason game number
three in the first half that he'll be
the starter and he's
be given every chance to be that guy and
you know take it by the reins and run
with it but I do think that this is a
situation where if things started off a
little ugly and they're 1 in 3 or maybe
they're 2 & 2 and they've somehow won
two games and Mariota hasn't played well
that I think Ryan Tannehill is at least
giving the coaching staff in the
organization the confidence ago hey if
it doesn't work out with Mariota we got
a guy here right now it's chomping at
the bit and you you you saw it I saw it
I mean he's made a number of great
throws the last two weeks in these
preseason games and certainly looks very
comfortable in that offense you know
it's it's almost like what the
Buccaneers had with were done and Mike
Alstott where ideally you have both guys
but it always seemed like one of them
was banged up okay so the other one
would carry a load right right until the
other one got healthy and then the other
one would get banged up I mean I feel
like with Mariota in Tannehill all right
Mario does he got until he gets banged
up and then he gets banged up we put in
tan ale and then when Tannehill gets
banged up Mario it'll be ready to go and
Willie you look at the two games last
year where they had to go with Blaine
Gabbert
especially week 17 a playoff playing
game if you have a better backup there
maybe you win that game and maybe you
make it to the postseason so I think
there's some some method to the madness
in Nashville and even if Ryan Tannehill
doesn't know it his mere presence pushes
Marcus Mariota like he's never been
pushed during his NFL career okay the
NFL pushing for an 18 game regular
season the NFL Players Association chris
has done a great job to date of creating
an impression that they're not
interested under any set of
circumstances in 18 regular season games
no way nohow and I've previously said
this sets the stage for the NFL to make
them an offer they can't refuse and for
the first time someone connected to NFL
PA leadership has essentially
acknowledged that there's an offer they
can't refuse out there that maybe they
would accept Richard Sherman the 49ers
cornerback in a member of the NFL PA
Executive Committee talking to Peter
King recently for the football morning
in America Peter King podcast he said
that as it relates to an 18 game regular
season it's highly unlikely the the
concession would have to be astronomical
which means
there is something the NFL can do now
would have to be astronomical but for
the first time there's an
acknowledgement that that it is
something that's negotiable even though
they want a ton for it it's no longer no
way nohow
there is a way there is a how and it's
going to be something huge for the NFLPA
and if they do that if they make an
offer they can't refuse then an 18-game
season is going to become a reality the
question is yeah will that best offer
from the NFL be something the players
say yeah okay we'll take it yeah it's
interesting and what is that offer that
I'll make the players take it because
yeah I don't I mean I don't think the
players want to do this but certainly
and you know this once is something we
talked about in the spring right I mean
we'd had my dad on the show at one point
because I think he felt through people
he knew in the NFL that the NFL
eventually was gonna make the players
and offer they couldn't refuse what is
that number for the NFL PA two extra
games well it can't just be the worth of
two extra games as it stands right now
those two extra games to get the players
to agree might have to count as four
extra games or six extra games because
you are taking years of the career away
from players within that you're you're
adding you know after after what is it
eight seasons of 18 games you're adding
another season to a guy's career right
more opportunities late in the year when
you're banged up and tired as is already
- now get even more banged up or have
another in for instance of a
career-ending injury all of those things
got to come into play that you have to
make it really worthwhile for the player
and and I would imagine it's gonna take
some type of offer like that from the
NFL and here's the problem in a salary
captain environment NFL PA president
Eric Winston has chimed in in this
regard in the past he has said that if
you just increased the cap then the star
players are going to get all that extra
money they need to dramatically increase
the minimum salaries as well to ensure
that all players benefit from these two
extra games and you're right it can't
just be 17 game checks turned into 19
game checks and it's the same overall
rate that extra pay has got to be
exponentially greater than the normal
rate to get them to take it on and you
know there's
things are gonna need to do they're
gonna need to expand the rosters is
gonna be other and yeah and if I'm the
NFLPA Chris I I
if they come to us and say what do you
want for 18 games nothing we're not
doing 18 games now if you want to make
us an offer right then we'll consider it
but we're not going to negotiate here if
you make us an offer that we can't
refuse we won't refuse it it's up to you
to put together an offer we can't refuse
we're not gonna engage you in this
discussion right because that's the
problem once they engage them 18 games
becomes an inevitability and this is the
closest thing to engagement that we've
seen it'll be interesting to see where
it goes from here all right last topic
and this gets back to replay review for
pass interference Chris I don't know if
you saw the play from the Rams cowboys
game late in the fourth quarter Saturday
night there was a ruling on the field of
no pass interference by offense or
defense
Sean McVeigh the Rams head coach threw
the flag and the end result was a
phantom defensive pass interference
penalty after nearly four minutes of
review presided over by al Riverrun some
5,000 miles away from Hawaii now
regardless of how we feel about our
River Ron's ability to properly in
real-time under that pressure of do it
now do it now and I think all of us
would make mistakes when expected to
make a rational reliable correct
decision in that moment where we feel
like everyone's watching us and everyone
is is doing this and singing the
jeopardy music it's not easy to do but
be that as it may
right now Chris it dawned on me recently
al Riverrun is the most powerful person
in football during the playing of games
because the only person who can for
every game grant or take away gigantic
chunks of field position based upon pass
interference calls and non calls
specifically defensive or he can wipe
out a 50-yard gain because he can say
there was offensive pass interference I
mean this guy has almost a god power
over the NFL games especially as it
relates to pass interference calls and
Nan calls and I don't know that it's
good for the NFL to have one person
having that much power over it's it's
on-field
rules application yeah let's start
how's he gonna do all this how is it
really I guy I really do I worry about
this you know there's eight games in one
o'clock when week one and you know
there's there's two other two other
replay reviews going on and all of a
sudden two other other games pass
interference is getting reviewed I mean
I don't know I just don't know how it's
gonna work this review you're talking
about in the Dallas Rams game you
mentioned it it took four minutes I mean
holy cow what's he gonna do if there's
four other place that need to be replay
reviewed during a complicated type play
like we saw in the Dallas Los Angeles
scenario we're seeing the unintended
consequences to here a little bit
already to with a legal contact and pass
interference
who was the ball in the air or not
because illegal contact is when the
quarterback still has the ball
that's not reviewable this is gonna piss
fans off too because they're gonna see a
legal contact on plays now and and then
a coach might think from the sideline
ooh that was a you know that was pass
interference and then a super slow
motion we're gonna look at it the ball
might still be in the quarterbacks hand
and now the unintended consequence might
be oh actually your own team the guy
that's challenging your own team had
passed interference when the ball was in
the air so no you challenge the thinking
you were gonna win something and in fact
you're gonna lose it now I think it's
gonna make like coaches kind of be
careful a little bit about how often
they throw this flag to a degree to to
make sure they see the totality of some
of these plays but yeah I'm not liking
this so far I just fired off an email to
Michael Senora of the NFL to find out
and it's more of a refresher there are
these little things that I learn about
and then you forget about them and then
you have to relearn them there are other
people in the room who will step in to
handle replay review if foul reveron is
busy with one game but you're then
you're transferring that that godpower
too right yeah and and and and it's
always been one of the concerns when it
comes to replay review at 3:45 Park
Avenue and I think it takes on an even
greater importance when we begin
reviewing subjective decisions again and
I'm gonna keep saying this every time
the opportunity arises Chris there's a
huge difference between did the guy get
two feet inbounds both
or he stepped out with possession of the
ball was his knee down before the ball
came out those are things that we can
look at and say objectively yes or no
what happened this whole idea of clear
and obvious evidence of significant
hindrance to the receiver that is
inherently subjective and you slow it
down you frame by frame and I don't know
what the hell they're seeing and for
some of these calls we've seen and the
one on Saturday night was the most
glaring I don't know how you call the
Cowboys defensive back for pass
interference on a 10-yard curl route
where the Rams receiver ran to the top
of the route and shoved the defensive
back to engage him so he could turn
around and get separation and the
defensive back joined in that push and
then the defensive back gets flagged for
your replay battle it's very right and
most of the contact happened before the
ball was even thrown like you're saying
contact before the ball is thrown right
so I I just I really am concerned and
and I really do think a lot of it comes
down to the ability of our River Ron or
anyone and maybe the answer is no one
can do this when you feel all that
pressure you know the anxiety the
needles on the back of your neck and and
people standing around you and you got
to make the decision quickly and what do
I really see here and how am I gonna and
how many times I have to look at it I
mean it was three minutes and 40 seconds
from the end of the play to the moment
that referee John Hussey began to
explain what the ruling was that's an
unacceptable delay if it should take
that long it should never be overturned
right so just sir would you feel better
if like just I'm throwing for instance
out there but I mean I would feel better
if I knew okay
Alvar of Iran's back there who I know
Al's got a tough job I know we're being
tough right here but listen now we know
this is the real deal Holyfield but
could you he got thrust into a job that
wasn't designed designed for Dean by
Andy not so as I said would you feel
better this is where maybe the NFL needs
to address this or go down here instead
of just having one king let's have three
kings I mean I would feel better if it
was Al River on Mike Pereira and Dean
Blandino in the room I really would I
would go okay here's three really smart
football guys who understand the rules
and now maybe they can come to a
consensus and maybe that would take some
of the doubt out of all of us to to just
go okay here's three reasonable human
beings who saw this way
maybe something like that because portal
isn't a really tough no-win situation
right now where I mean my head would be
popping off I think if I had to deal
with officiating week one or a normal
week in the NFL what they need to do and
and I know that this is gonna require
the the swallowing of some pride the
suppression of some ego and the
expenditure of some money that the NFL
would rather not spend they need to call
Dean Blandino and they need to offer him
between five and ten million dollars a
year to come back and take that job over
there period that's what they need to do
that's what we want 3% of that now that
we're asking for five or ten for you
three percent I want 10 percent baby no
the Dean come to me he'll give me three
probably get more creeper set you'll get
your money's worth Dean and get your
money's worth baby all right but but
that's what they need to do and look I'm
trying to be fair - I'm trying to be
fair to the NFL yeah they they don't
value the position Dean Blandino has
told me that that is a very diplomatic
way of saying they're cheap yeah and
it's amazing how much money they have
and how many ways they will spend the
money but on certain things they won't
and and this is now the most important
and powerful job in the NFL it's more
powerful than the commissioner and I'd
rather have the commissioner handle the
pass interference replay reviews at
least he's getting paid the money to
deal with the pressure say I feel bad
for Al yeah I mean think about how this
wears on you and the dread can you
imagine every Saturday night went out
where everyone goes to bed knees
thinking oh god what's gonna happen
tomorrow during the 12 hours that
probably goes barren and and wait for
the next fire right am I gonna get it
right am I gonna get it wrong and what
are buttholes like Florio gonna say
about me the next day I wouldn't want
that job though I mean gosh think how
about you must feel for me I got a deal
with your butt Holness every day all
right
I probably call it it's a half hour not
that they give us a time limit but I'd
say a half hours probably as much as we
can say enough over so after we say
first after you say butt hole a few
times yes yeah that's enough over time
on pft ot we don't have to do PFT ot ot
just ick with PMT ot everybody thanks
for your time appreciate you sticking
around and listen to the stuff we have
to say we'll be back Tuesday I knew
Chris Sims on button come
Tuesday a PFT p.m. coming later today
and plenty of content around the clock
at Pro Football Talk comc a Tuesday
peace
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports